you
hi everyone it's Jerry man just calm and
going to give the computer a try this is
a 15-2 game so let's see what we get
hmm well it's already gonna be pretty
different I don't see b3 too often by
the computer
alright let's place a pawn in the center
my idea is just to get this guy outside
the pawn chain or and now that's the big
question
I could go more reserved with the e6
Bishop e7 but I like deploying the
bishop so I'm gonna go with that and
then e 6 they take on f6 now one thing I
don't have to worry about is with the
pawn on b3 sometimes there's the
drawback with the bishop playing to f5
in that Queen b3 could hit you where
you're sensitive on b7 so this is
typical computer chess obstructing the C
pawn so I don't have to worry about a C
pawn strike at my Center I wonder a
little bit about h6 just pervert
preserving my bishop against Knight h4
yeah I think it's time well spent to
maintain my bishop although I would
regard him as my expendable Bishop of
the two he's more important the dark
square bishop I didn't consider this
move
Bishop here be a problem can always play
a night here give the night a kick it
plays into d4
oh I should also be aware that Bishop
takes Knight as a threat
I can't recapture with my queen because
of Knight takes c7 so currently my queen
is let's say overloaded having to watch
over c7 in the night probably Bishop e7
on Bishop e5 I have night a6 and then I
could kick the night one move later Wow
surprised at how tricky this already is
I was just seeing Bishop e7 Bishop e5
Knight a six-night d4 hitting the bishop
and my knight here and if I run away
with him then there's Bishop takes
Knight followed by Knight to c6 well ok
so what could I do
I mean I could think about c6 actually
well I could actually think about let's
say a6 Bishop takes Knight in taking
with the pawn or we were at Knight d7
isn't that much simpler Knight d7 stops
Bishop b5 connects the Knights yeah I'm
gonna go with that ok really
I am certainly happy with that ok I
don't uh oh okay I see all right well
very interesting early on less than 10
moves in and there's already tricks with
Bishop b5 push and then sacrifices to
pawns for the rook idea huh yeah okay so
if I backup Bishop check if I block with
the knight Knight e5 hits so Bishop back
Bishop check c6 Knight takes pawn takes
Bishop takes
I'd have to play King East seven I don't
like that idea huh I'd much rather go in
for this variation where they get the
two two pawns in the rook for the two
minor pieces where my Bishop is already
deployed I think it might go for that
uh-huh let me consider this once more
let's say Bishop all the way back on g6
it's still vulnerable tonight here so
Bishop h7 Bishop check c6 Knight takes
pawn takes Bishop takes King here and
that doesn't feel good at all hmm the
alternative is to allow the doubling of
the off pawns I'm not sure I'm not quite
sure what I should do here hmm yeah I
don't think it's a wise decision to
enter these complications where they
give up the two minor pieces for the two
pawns in the rook and my king is on e7
obstructing my Kings side development
that said where should I go with my dark
square Bishop mm-hmm I think d6 is a
good spot let's go to d6 no they're
going for this okay well I think it's
under much more favorable circumstances
okay they are going to go for this
material it's a quite common thing to
see by the computer so they're gonna
sack the two minor pieces get two pawns
and a rook yeah let's let's try this
imbalance I'm much much happier about
playing King here in this case because
my bishop has already developed so King
up here and let's see how they work
against these two bishops no
Inbetweeners so let's do this alright so
quite an interesting position already
and what to do with my light square
bishop I want to just back up play rip
to c8 and Castle by hand
bishop here provokes c6 maybe not a bad
idea because this does create some
weaknesses
so maybe Bishop here f3 and then Bishop
back I really don't see anything too
wrong with that let's do this try and
provoke some weaknesses okay
I'm kicking around kick me around once
more now trying to hunt down the dark
square Bishop hmm okay I don't know if I
want to give that up so quickly Bishop
c5 Knight c7 really isn't so much about
er play here but then d4 on the other
hand is probably something useful unlike
f3 so I don't know if I don't want I
want to run into this tempo gaining move
well actually what what more am I going
to do how do I preserve my dark square
Bishop if I play Bishop be a queen c1
probably happens hmm I could always just
get my rook here I don't want to hmm I
don't want to what I don't want to be so
quick to give up my dark square bishop
he's he's really good huh good play
Queen c6 Knight takes pawn and that gets
trapped with Queen c5 and maybe I have
to do that yeah I'm just a very fearful
of Bishop let's say there should be a
queen c1 queen a3 with check and the
knight jumping in here let's just
consider this but should be a queen c1
yeah I mean in the end I'd have to give
up my Bishop I think the knight would be
an intolerable here I don't have time to
get my rook here and let's say Knight to
e8 offsetting and this Knight
fish up here yeah yeah I think I have to
maybe do this so they're gonna skip that
guy up take with the Queen and that move
huh Wow now this is this move this
square right here is immediately
sticking out to me I could clamp down on
this structure I think I quite like this
move here huh
surprising see that could also go for
Queen check but huh maybe here first
yeah let's do this move first this is a
very surprising move d3 okay so I could
give a check or no no no no that's
probably shouldn't be so quick for that
I'm gonna I'm gonna throw my rook right
into c3 hmm my bishop is not playing the
structure is really killing my little
light square Bishop rook c8 pretty
natural E 5 is another one to consider
I'd really like to get my knight here
because where there are these extra
pawns where white house a young majority
it makes it difficult to really put them
to use I should probably start with rook
here half-opened file keep pressure on C
and maybe tuck my king the way II five F
four is not working have to be mindful
of a 5 f 4 takes push with the fork and
Queen takes rook here stuff 'if i've a
knight move and then f6
hmm or just reposition my knight
maybe I don't know maybe I could do
without a 5 yeah let's reposition my
knight I don't think he has a purpose on
f6 I feel like I have good control over
this position
I have said something like that before
hmm maybe maybe a queen trait is not a
bad idea here again I like the control I
have over the Queen side how do they get
active with their rooks they'd have to
move the being a pawns but he's a
tremendous thorn maybe hmm could
reposition try and get in here if I
could somehow get my knight here that
would be fantastic
g5 clamp down on f4 no that'll still
happen hmm maybe f4 is the way they're
going
maybe I should offer a queen exchange
let me let me try this
Queen c5 Queen here I'm hitting c2 hmm
okay this is probably a poisoned pawn
even if I win if they get activity so
let's not go up on hunting mm hm how can
I get my knight to a good know a better
square hmm think queen here the queen of
trade will be avoided I'm gonna still
try it though hmm there huh
okay hmm let's just go here he needs to
do something
different okay my bishop is kind of
struggling here not sure how to get him
working if I play f6f-5 sing a hit or
even Queen g3 hmm Wow okay hmm
what about f6 Queen g3 no I'm gonna back
up I want to meet maybe a pawn push with
an advance and also there's this idea in
mind f5 here and then f6 okay I got to
keep it closed playing with the minor
pieces this might not be bad are they
gonna play off six through playing f6
they they are playing f6 huh okay let's
let's hang on here though take what the
pawn take what the night I drop you five
he's unprotected so I move like Queen
here is gonna happen pawn takes Queen a3
kingi seven Queen takes pawn bishop here
I got to try this you know King here and
then Bishop here I think positions are
right I want the Queen's off oh man
oh I'm busted my bishop is a goner mmm I
think I might need to sack my bishop Wow
out of nowhere huh ah man Age 5 this was
a bad idea
Queen to c3 hmm I wonder what it would
have been a better plan let's see if I
could still try and put up some
resistance there's really no way to save
this bishop is there because night here
aged five he has to defend this square
yeah my queen is so out of play
she looks she looks good she's in a hole
but this was this is gone I guess I'll
try something like this huh maybe maybe
not too fast just ready to pile up on
the F pond okay and
defense what are they doing I'm gonna go
after that Bishop okay finally they got
the bishop queen here just be active hmm
let's see
rooks there to defend if I could
reposition my knight hmm now the Queen's
going elsewhere huh hmm can I hold on
for a draw somehow if I could get my
knight here it would be worth the rook
maybe more night here there's Queen
check if I try to run away get my king
to g7 uh yeah let's try and lose that
pawn but maybe they are they can
miscalculate here i'm a repossessor look
at how fast they are they hmm mmm
interesting what would you do on rook h6
and then Queen h4 idea let's try that
whoa
feels like I should have something here
no Queen here well I think I have a
perpetual actually rook h3 and then I
could take here the Queen is not playing
I should have something let's try this
and then Queen back maybe I think I have
a perpetual at least the queen is out of
play no I do not have a perpetual that
was a poison pond
hmm like I have to do this they could
have a perpetual I gotta come over here
though
you know this might be for petrol their
queen is offside bang sometime yeah I
think I just have to go back and forth
hmm okay how do I make a perpetual take
here give a check I should have
something hmm should be perpetual right
just don't allow the rook to block okay
I think I know how to hold this to a
draw I don't think I have anything
better and we're gonna have a repetition
a very unexpected Wow huh
I really started to doubt myself I must
say and I know you've uh you here to my
voice but right around here where I lost
the bishop I mean I was really close to
just hitting that resign button but I
mean and yet you look at these guys over
here hmm I was able to threaten to get
this knight in here I wonder I wonder if
I missed some when actually when this
White Queen went astray and I got my
knight right around here after g3 I
would not be surprised if there was some
something I could do here I cannot move
my knight into a four just yet because
it's a pin here
hmm yeah this was quite an interesting
game starting with b3 and going in for
this imbalance I have to check my my
thought my decisions with you know
should I have should I have played
Bishop d6 or back my bishop up I think
it was the correct decision to develop
in this at this point have the King on
e7 it's a much more harmonious setup and
what could I have done different here
this will be another point to check out
can I really maintain the dark square
Bishop I'm not so sure about that
because of the queen c1 Queen C 1 to a3
idea this really felt weird III I think
stockfish would frown upon this move I
mean well actually another thing you
know when I'm looking at a bit more d3
is aimed at restricting this guy you
know doing something more natural like
this then I have a target Rick over to
c8 and then here hmm if they could
somehow get this and then this would be
a quite a quite a tough position to
battle hmm yeah pretty pretty
interesting game let me before I check
it out with stockfish actually give me a
moment here and bring it up okay there
we go I still don't want to look at it
just yet with the computer I just had to
reload the game there but this this
position is really interesting right
around here I wonder how to really go
forward with developing a plan because
this is this is certainly the type of
position is it's like how to get your
pieces functioning well this pawn has a
nice grip over the Queen side there's
really nothing going on I don't think
for white on the Queen side because of
this guy and so the attention is
shifting over towards the Kings side
where hey amazingly lost my bishop I
mean how how much more powerful would
this position have been if I'm still
playing with this guy I know they've the
there was some
connected with hunting down my bishop I
had play on on the G file and they
created some weaknesses on the G file by
moving this H pawn down uh Wow
could I have better controlled the
kingside is what I'm wondering because I
have control over the Queen side if I
could control the King side of the board
then I have good control over the
position it could slowly improve but how
could I get it to a point in the game
where I have that ability to slowly
improve I'll be interested to see what
the computer suggests surround this
point because I really couldn't come up
with something maybe I should have
considered 'if I've much sooner instead
of with this natural move maybe an idea
connected with e5 and then somehow
getting a knight in here real quick
although at the moment it's not a
reliable home yeah maybe maybe I could
have gone in this direction
maybe this idea actually ee v and g5 but
one thing i can say is that i would be
much i would certainly be fearful about
playing g4 with this rook still in his
home square so only after Castle maybe
g5 yeah maybe this is something I could
have gone for g5 and then yeah I mean
this seems like a nice idea I have a
grip over this square this is still not
heading and then here and then look to
reposition my knight somewhere you know
I think that this would have been better
bishop move a knight move maybe even f6
then my bishop could come over here in
case things open up of our on the Queen
side I think that this would have been
better not just because it's a lock
position and that's usually a good
strategy against computer but just an
objectively good decision a good plan g5
+ e5 instead of going with this
the timing became an issue I'm pretty
sure because after this move and Castle
if I play e5 now you know f4 does
hit just yet but I think this move and
then f4 can hit because on takes there's
this fork and after here I'm getting
pinned so the timing was not quite right
because I played this very natural move
rook to c8 that's my thought at least I
don't have time now for this and this to
stop the f4 break hmm okay well let's
confirm things with the stockfish
there's a few interesting things to
really check out with this one okay
oh let us see where there's an
improvement Knight c3 83 Knight here
doesn't like that because of what I did
in the game Knight B to d7 okay
yeah I already have to be concerned this
is what I was pointing out this natural
move Bishop e5 in fact what I suspected
in here is just getting killed I think
because of Knight B to d4 Knight is hit
bishops hit if I save him there's even
an in-between check but this is the
thing I didn't like with at least this
move and it's just a wreck over here on
the Queen side and so I already have to
be pretty careful with c7 and doing this
there's Bishop takes Knight at least and
III really don't want to take like this
I know they've been wrested the bishop
hair but yeah I really wanted to steer
clear of that so we went for this
imbalance Knight B to d4 and if I back
my Bishop up wants to go Bishop g4
Bishop b5 check it appears to be okay
with this but yeah this is very
difficult to play King side development
bit tricky so yeah I wanted to have
position but with my bishop right here
so I went for that Bishop d6 yeah it
doesn't like going in for the sacrifice
in computer Impossibles eyes it's it's
good to give up the two minor pieces for
our rook and two pawns but the big
question will remain can you open up
files to get activity for the rooks see
it likes black here even though black is
down material minor pieces are strong
bishop g6 and I went for g4 and Bishop
c5 it wants to hang on to the bishop
this is what concerned me oh I didn't
consider this in-between move Queen c6 I
just have it in my mind that if I move
off this diagonal Queen c1 and yeah sure
enough well even now Queen d2 now that
the D pawn is removed but this idea of
getting on this diagonal and the knight
jumping in here is quite a bother it'll
be different story for my rook was
already on the C file and then maybe I
could just go here but it's it's quite
uncomfortable to have the knight and
queen the the White Queen and the knight
coordinated on the d6 square so I played
here doesn't seem to have a problem with
that
still slight pull for black likes Queen
C 5 and now d4 ok so I'm at least that
fun being anchored there is fine it's
okay with rook to see ain't here but let
me look a bit closer at e5 let's say
Castle and wood g5 be an idea yeah a lot
of different ideas the evaluation I
don't know how beneficial will really be
to pay too much attention to that I
think yeah the having a nice grip over
f4 is good
Queen d2 preparing to maybe eliminate
the C phone now rook c8 g4 I would have
I'd be happy to see G for now h4 ooh
okay maybe this is too fast I was
talking about h4 happening when the rook
was still on the home square but I guess
here it's still hitting and then I have
to deal with the opening up at the H
file as it has even I wouldn't be so
fearful of this h4 move if my knight was
in a little bit of a better position
like e six this is a dream square right
now for a knight defends g5 looks to
jump in f f5 r f4 so maybe with a little
bit more preparation I could be getting
in g5 and maybe it's wise to hold off on
this move because it is very committal
so I think this is this is a moment
where I could do a little bit more prep
work and by that I mean improving my
pieces first and only then make the
committal moves later okay so rook c8 97
first okay I did do 97 clean D to it
like c5 I play queen c5 and I'm going
astray here I was maybe in a way playing
hope chest
Queen c3 hopefully we exchanged Queens
maybe maybe I do better to keep the
Queen's on the board
hmm not sure
look there likes f6 here yeah this is
where I couldn't quite figure out how to
construct my King side pawns f6 and baby
step an avenue for the bishop to
reposition him and on f4 it's not so
quick it's not so easily seen how a
white opens up the position any any pawn
advance could be met with the pawn
advance of my own keeping it locked hmm
okay so f6 instead of this yeah I'm
going astray here with Queen c3 I ship
back f4 they didn't like Bishop h7 King
f8 King f8 or Bishop h7 I think a
up okay can you fake it still holding
even 'if I've have six night takes hmm I
did not want to do that but maybe it's
alright
it takes I don't want to give this up
but I guess Knight g4 I'm not quite
because of Queen here and the knight is
hit and so too is a f7 threatening mate
a knight here it just gets kicked so I'm
not quite there to let's say get the
knight into this Square be a much
different situation if I could manage
that but the timing is just not there
did not want to give up the e5 pawn and
I didn't realize the pressure I did not
see it at all that my Bishop was in
trouble with them grabbing my H pawn and
then throwing their H phone at me but
what about this final position coming up
here yeah I was really sweating here I
was really thinking I'm lost but I came
up with something some play against
their King tough position to assess here
huh it likes white buy +2 and white
wasn't converting this in h5 let's go
with Bishop takes e4 hmm like queen g4
Wow +3 White was at one point and then
this slipped away huh that's really
surprising okay King f8 and now there
going astray she's needed for defense
rook e 2 F 1 is better within Queen h5
rook F 3 yeah I think she needs to stay
over here the computer was going for
more material huh
that's really neat to see a game like
this where computer has such an
advantage I mean plus plus 3 I mean I
imagine it's just going to keep climbing
with some time here but huh ok doesn't
like the Queen going in this direction
now already of Knight f8 was I ever
winning at this point
96 no I am winning oh man
Queen g3 I'm at minus 3 what I play rook
there and now it's a draw it's back to a
win with g3 here let's look at this
position it likes Queen H 5 plus 4 here
threatens mate and also
frees up my night to move yeah it's as
if in this position surprisingly enough
even though there's these two connected
passed pawns they're far off
it's like I'm playing with let's let's
count of nine five and three how much is
that okay we got 17 point it's like
viewing this position where I have 17
attacking pieces or 17 attacking points
versus 10 his queen is not even playing
she's out of play Wow these two pawns
seal her off this rook has a nice
defensive duty defending the F pawn and
a multi-purpose fees here defensive and
aggressive but on Queen h5 rook g2 now
Knight g5 Queen f5 and I guess I have
check and then Knight h3 and I'm getting
one of the rooks the King cannot move
and still be defending both of these
rooks have to give up the Queen ah man I
wonder in this position how I could have
done better I know I was pressed for
time as usual but you know when I saw
this pin here I mean what did i do i
played rook h3 which is still winning
huh
this is still winning but yeah i get i
saw my knight couldn't move why wasn't i
much quicker to get out of this pin
which would then allow my knight to
contribute also I was focused a bit much
on a bit too much I think on plankton to
f/4g five squares excellent as well Wow
so white was winning a +3 advantage and
now I'm winning with what's close to a
three-point advantage now taking however
is going to be a draw and I think this
is an assessment that won't change from
here
I have to go for a perpetual and then I
ended up getting a perpetual but what
was still the win right here with the
move I played rook h3 was still fine
right here
rook g2 what could I have done better
Queen f3 huh hmm what's the deal with
that oh this is at least permitting
Knight f4 tete no it's not no it's not
what am I talking about pawn takes with
check so what's the idea rook e 2 e 2
some kind of finesse here with
inconveniencing the rook and then rook
to h1 stuff I wonder about Queen h5
immediately allows the king to play here
so there's some difference the rook
being on this square e 2 instead of e 1
it's a Queen f3 rook here and now what
would happen if on king f2 and now
Knight g5 and then once again it's
suggesting to give up the Queen what
about here
no this is tough to see rook h1 and now
there's this threatened Wow amazing this
was a really a really interesting game
uh not too many games like this that
I've played against the computer where
had that kind of shift with the
evaluation but could certainly see how
the computer is deficient in a way with
coming out in this direction not sensing
the danger coming out in this direction
here going pawn hunting looking to get
this guy rolling once the a pond is is
taken out but not seeing deep enough
this idea of the knight really being of
equal or greater value than let's say a
rook when he's on this square in in
close proximity to the white king
position it's uh a really interesting
game
hmm okay well anyhow as usual feel free
to leave any feedback on this one I
really enjoy playing this this game and
hope you got a thing or two from it feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below and I'll catch you
in the next one that's all for now
take care